Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday.
Uh,
May 28th,
2018 what's going on?
How,
whew.
Oh,
sorry.
I just had to cry it out of me
on the motorcycle.
Oh,
Jesus.
Ah,
if only kids knew how to play basketball these days.
And I'm actually talking about the Cavaliers and the Celtics.
If we just played basketball in the end,
if we just played basketball,
we actually could have,
why didn't think we'd win?
Won Two games of that series.
I was just like the Barn James is Lebron James.
If we just fucking played,
but I didn't see one pick and roll that whole fucking game.
Maybe I missed it.
I mean,
I was having a couple as I was sitting there just watching it.
It's game seven,
you know,
stressing out ahead.
I had to take the edge off the,
you know,
I was talking to a buddy of mine.
I swear to God,
if you take a fucking three pointer with nobody underneath and you miss that
should be in the stat sheet as a turnover.
That's all.
I'm going to
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
This is what happens when everybody in the league is a fucking one and done guy.
You know,
they never took a physics class or I dunno,
ever fucking had a ruler and fucking measured
dude.
We would,
there was like six minutes left.
We're like down by,
I don't know,
four,
five,
six,
seven points.
We just start taking threes every time we'd go down the court,
like,
like there was like five seconds left.
Like the crowd was counting down.
I don't know.
Having said that,
I got to tell you right now,
Lebron James,
uh,
in my mind,
leapfrog,
Cobe Bryant taking that team to the NBA finals.
MMM.
I just,
I just think Colby would have been too far.
He just didn't have the,
he just didn't have that thing.
He would just look at everybody on the bench,
like the bumps they were and be like,
what the fuck?
And would just walk into the front office and be like,
I'm not playing with this shit.
Get me better guys or I'm fucking leaving.
That's,
that's how he got his title.
He was also a beast.
You know.
I'm a Celtics fan,
so I always have to shit on them a little bit.
You know what I mean?
It's either me or shack.
Um,
the Black Mamba,
he's ice cold,
except when he was crying in the front office.
Jesus belt.
Can you stay on topic?
Sorry.
This has nothing to do with Colby.
Bryan East,
one of the greatest players of all fucking time.
All right.
I'm just a fucking butt hurt Celtics fan right now.
Who's team way over achieved?
So I says I should be happy.
Um,
but Lebron James,
what the fuck that guy did?
Jesus Christ.
Um,
unbelievable.
Speechless.
I don't,
I don't know what to say.
And uh,
from what I've heard,
the warriors are a little banged up.
Um,
they got that game seven tonight.
Uh,
so I mean,
I guess,
you know,
as,
as a fan of basketball and more importantly,
competition,
I have to root for the Cavaliers or the Houston Rockets.
I mean,
do you just,
you can't root for,
uh,
a pile on team unless they're playing another pile on team.
Isn't that how it works?
And admittedly,
the Celtics had one in 2008.
I didn't watch that team the whole year.
You know,
I watched during the playoffs and we played the Lakers and I was like,
all right,
I'll pile on t verse your pile on t whatever.
I'll do it.
Um,
but I,
congratulations.
Congratulations to the Cleveland Cavaliers.
Lebron James.
Without a doubt.
I mean,
you got,
I would put that guy like,
I dunno.
It's hard.
It's hard when you start talking to Oscar Robertson,
Bill Russell,
not,
I don't know where the fuck he is,
but he's passed Koby and the modern era.
I'd have to say that it's him and Jordan and a,
I know a lot of your young kids right now who didn't watch Michael Jordan.
Uh,
you know,
you go back and you go on Youtube and you watch his highlights and that type of
that guy,
he literally changed the game.
Um,
I,
I can't,
I can't stress that enough.
Like the game changed.
He didn't dominate the game the way Colby did.
He literally changed it.
Like,
oh,
I didn't know you could fucking do that.
I had no idea you could do that.
My only knock against Lebron James is what?
He fucking blocked that shot and then just stood there,
basking in his own amazing,
amazing amazingness or whatever.
And then the announcer Jackson goes every once in a while.
I said something every once in a while you make a play that's so unbelievable.
You have to stand there and admire it.
And I was sitting there like the oldest old man ever go in like that.
That yellow fucking y'all.
I can't even believe how I can't even believe how amazing I am.
The fuck down the court.
You know,
he can't really say to help out your teammates.
He had a ball in his back,
but just what the fuck was he doing back there?
Standing there for like 20 minutes like do you understand what that dumb look on
his face?
Like he just stopped a Scud missile.
You blocked a shot.
I Dunno,
I am officially,
this is how old I am.
Okay.
This is how I was actually watching old school TV shows and like I turn 50 next
month as much as it's fucking with me.
I wouldn't change when I was born to live now as a younger person and I'm for
the simple reason that when I was a kid,
this is what a theme song sounded like on a TV show.
Sounds like a fucking porno.
That's all people playing that come on.
Get to the fucking horns.
[inaudible]
dude.
Nice be my what?
That you knew somebody was getting fucked up.
Knows we're all fucking people.
You know something?
After they played that theme song,
they didn't stand in the studio admiring what the fuck they just did.
Other than that,
I love Lebron James.
I do.
I'm just breaking his fucking balls and I also love the city of Cleveland and I
even still love the city.
CLEVELAND,
even after about five or 6,000 Cleveland Cavalier fans.
What at me sending me fucking all kinds of shit over social media like,
like they weren't,
they didn't have a Cleveland steamer in their fucking pants.
Whatever the fuck.
I hate those stupid jokes,
by the way.
You know what?
A dirty sage edges.
No,
I doubt and yet keep the job to yourself.
It's all the same Fugate.
When you stick your Dick in his shit and you shove it up her nose and you go,
God bless you,
but you say it in Spanish with water,
bubbler jokes.
Those are all jokes for people who don't know how to make a move.
Right.
Did you stand there?
Hey,
this one's cool.
We'll just take you.
Can you fucking pilot?
Cool.
Um,
oh,
that gives me do shells.
I hate,
I always fucking hated those jokes anyways.
I like,
oh,
we used to trash Patrice when he used to do those jokes on stage.
We still get Patricia doing street jokes.
You're doing street jokes.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
I'm all over the fucking map here,
Simon.
I'm shaken off a game.
Seven loss.
Um,
I was just psyched that we got to these two conference finals and all of his
sons like,
Holy Shit,
we could actually win this fucking thing.
Then I'm like,
and if the warriors loose to the rockets,
who gives a fuck about the rockets?
We always beat the rockets in the file.
We beat him in 81 and 86.
Um,
we're going to have the TRIFECTA.
Oh,
Billy started dreaming.
Um,
anyways,
so was Cleveland fans who were talking all this crazy shit.
All right.
Yeah.
You're lying to yourself if you forgot about that.
Jason Tatum Dunk on Lebron James.
Okay.
That right there is what's known as a changing of the guard.
That was like the first time Shaq having problems with his big toe.
Like that's the beginning of the end.
Okay.
And a new chapters coming in and it's dressed in green and white.
All right.
Seat.
But this one fucking guy,
I trashed him on Twitter.
He gave me some shit and he had his stupid Cavaliers Jersey,
you know,
and has had on,
with this game seven look on his face.
I said,
but he was wearing his seat
belt.
I Dunno.
Some Cleveland plans when they look up in the rafters and they start counting
banners,
they forget that an eastern conference championship is not an NBA title.
Alright.
And a division title banner is,
is literally,
that's like up.
Like that's something you give to a millennial.
Like,
all right,
you did something.
Um,
I don't know.
Alan got like five people gave me shit.
Why am,
why am I doing this right now?
Why am I being so childish?
Um,
Oh God,
we were right fucking there.
We were right there.
Um,
anyways,
and I'm not going to do that dumb shit of lagoons.
Do so and so was there.
Your won fair and square.
Everybody gets hurt.
Lebron's heart radio's probably all fucked up from carrying those people.
Anyways,
congratulations.
That really didn't sound like a congratulatory fucking 10 minutes here,
but that's,
that's what I was trying to get to.
Congratulations to Cleveland.
All right.
Even like eagles fan started giving me shit.
It's just like,
dude,
you know,
I,
I you fucking serious right now.
Good Lord.
And The Philadelphia.
When did Philly ever start talking shit about sports?
This is what I want all of you guys to do.
What is the championship combination to open your city county championships?
Ours is five,
six,
eight,
17.
Uh,
then unlocks to safe and all the rings pour out.
What happens in Philly.
Philly is two,
two,
three,
one.
Yeah,
go fuck yourselves.
You fucking green.
Cons.
You hang around long enough,
you're going to fucking win one.
That was another one.
This guy was giving me shit on the Celtics won like 11 championships before
there was anybody.
It's like,
all right,
well since then we won six.
Stop talking about the Cavaliers.
Like they're an expansion team.
They been in the league for almost 50 seasons.
Fucking Miami each showed up in 88.
I think they've won more than the Celtics.
Whether they went one they've been for,
they've won four.
Um,
I dunno.
Why am I trashing cities?
I don't,
I don't want to try.
I don't give a fuck about Philly.
I like Philly.
I like Cleveland.
I like all of this shit.
I'm just fucking,
you know,
it still stinks that I lost.
I,
like I said,
I wish I don't even fucking hate the Yankees anymore.
You can't hate them.
They're all basically,
they added one free agent.
Other than that civil team,
it's just a,
I think I hate the Lakers the most just because I live out here,
you know?
I'd say that was,
yeah,
probably just because I live out here and then Canadian fans,
but they just,
you know,
chasing their own fucking tails so they don't even matter anymore.
I don't know,
I guess,
I guess I'm just not mad anymore.
I mean,
I'm still mad,
but I guess it probably is childhood issues.
Wow.
Well,
why the fuck do I even watch sports?
All right guys.
I'm going to end this podcast and I just had an epiphany.
None of this matters.
Um,
and he wasn't fucking with you.
God dammit.
Oh God.
Oh.
What game seven state game.
Seven loss stinks.
It really stinks.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Um,
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I mean,
I,
I've,
I haven't watched the NBN so long.
I know.
I watched the Celtics like all last season.
I watched him and,
uh,
I just,
I just cannot get over running down the court and just fucking stopping.
And EFT teammates haven't even settled and just pulling up and taken to three
and just not getting yanked out of the fucking game.
The only thing that makes said,
okay is the other teams are doing it too.
It's like watching this high skilled like game at the [inaudible],
you know,
there's no place.
Everybody just met each other,
you know,
you just fucking
out.
They're trying to burn calories.
Um,
all right,
we'll let it go.
Okay,
I'll let it go.
How bad ass is that fucking theme song?
It's from the streets of San Francisco by the way.
I've been trying to find the original one,
but I kill my best.
I can find his,
they,
Henry Man sees man Sini version of it.
That was the heyday
of,
uh,
the white cop chasing the minority actors down the street and the only role that
he was going to get that decade,
you know,
um,
they should,
they should go back and they should do a documentary and all those fucking guys,
you know,
like who has the record?
Like what black actor in the 70s had the record for the most times he did a
scene where he was running down an alley,
being chased by the cops.
You know,
when you get to the fence,
that's the scene I always wanted to do.
You get to the chain link fence,
you get like,
you know,
a couple of rungs up and then they grab you back.
You like,
Nah,
they fucking drag you off
when you go in freckles.
Huh?
You know,
hurry.
It's something.
Sorry man.
I just don't go nowhere.
Um,
anyways,
congratulations.
Another congratulations.
I'm just,
I'm just being,
this is me in a very generous,
thankful mood.
It's Memorial Day,
right?
Thank in the troops,
the people that made the ultimate sacrifice,
you know,
it's a bit of a drop off to thank a fucking professional basketball team after
you thank the troops.
But uh,
you know,
congratulations to Daniel Ricardo winning his first,
uh,
race,
a Formula One race in Monaco.
How about that?
That's the race I want to go to.
And it's probably the most boring f one race cars that race is all about
qualifying.
That's still race.
Whoever fucking wins the pole position.
I mean,
they're racing in those little ass fucking streets.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
You know why those streets are so small over there.
It's not because the city is so old and they used to just ride a horse down and
it's because that's a sovereign city and that's Illuminati money and they like
the bitches skinny.
They like them young and thin.
Okay,
so that's that stay locked the door test.
If they can walk down the street without the hips touching either building,
uh,
then they'll have their current wife disposed of.
Yeah,
I think that's what they do.
And then they stay young.
Evidently somebody sent me this fucking thing in here.
I think this is how they stay young.
Somebody wrote to me,
he said for skin injections.
Your bill,
what gives in Hollywood?
Uh,
my girlfriend show showed me a video of an actress on Ellen talking about
injecting for skin cells.
Imported from Korea.
Korean circumcisions.
Sorry.
Into her face to look young.
Get out of their bill.
We can't have you injecting dick skin into your face for roles.
The fuck's going on.
Um,
what do you mean what the fuck is going on?
We are the leaders of how to stay young out here in Hollywood.
Okay.
What do you,
what do you think you'll Rogaine came from?
What do you think your,
your Grecian formula is going to come from?
Huh?
What do you think all your workouts come from?
They come from Hollywood.
All your fad diets.
That's us.
Okay.
We came up with all of that.
You know why?
Cause you consider always trashing us.
You hold us to a higher standard,
okay?
You look to us to see what the future of vanity is.
You look to us to make it,
okay?
Okay.
Botox started out here.
Now looking,
it's all over the country.
You're all fucking doing it.
All these real fucking housewives.
Huh?
Y'All made fun of us and now look at you.
You're all on steroids.
You get in the fucking good hair plugs because people out here in Hollywood,
you know had the decency to stick those ant legs into their fucking heads
to let these doctors make mistakes with their own face until it becomes safe
enough that you could sneak into some fucking back alley and get the same
procedure done to you when you start getting your man tits.
All right sir.
How dare you make fun of Hollywood.
Thanks to our self involvement.
You'll be able to wear a tank top well into your sixties you're welcome sir.
I mean I,
who's more fucking arrogant?
Cleveland Cavalier fans talking shit like they own the NBA when all they ever do
is show up in the finals to be the Washington generals to whatever the fuck that
set that one year when they won.
Um
Huh.
Or you regular fucking people who sit there and go in these fucking celebrities.
They need to be taken down a peg and Yeti,
Yeti Yada fucking Yetta.
Let me tell you something there.
Grill master now give to their foreman grill or whatever type of fucking cookery
you have in your goddamn kitchen.
Huh?
With your little fucking makeover in your sad little fucking house,
you know?
And then you turn on the TV to see what a dream looks like and who's standing
there?
Me and my bald fucking head.
By the way,
I'm not gonna lie to you guys for my 50th birthday.
I think I'm going to give myself hair plugs.
I think I've earned them.
Okay.
I'd like to brush my teeth,
you know,
and not stare at the sink.
Okay.
I would like to look up and see something that I like and you know,
I just want to live my truth,
you know,
that's all that I'm doing.
And Hey,
you know,
if hair plugs are going to make me feel better than I say,
I should do it.
And you know something.
I think it's time that I gave myself permission to look sexy again.
Um,
why in the fuck would you ever
like,
I could see if you,
if you had American for skin cells,
all right.
But like,
why would you get for skin cells imported from a country that we're really not
getting along with?
At least not half of it.
You know,
why don't you just get your botox from China?
It's probably where it's from.
Right?
Said make them China's Ted.
Um,
yeah,
people are out of their fucking nights.
MMM.
I am doing my damnedest to stay in shape,
but I am going to age fucking naturally.
That's it.
You know what I mean?
Other than the,
I get a varicose vein in my left leg,
you know,
that looks like a goddamn roadmap to fucking Albuquerque.
You know,
I might get that taken out some point.
I keep meaning to get around to it,
but I never wear shorts,
you know,
cause I respect people,
all these fatties out there wearing half shirts,
acting like they're brave.
You're not,
you discussed it and everybody should point at you.
Like we're in the invasion of the body snatchers.
Okay.
I don't care that you fat,
but you know,
you put on put on a whole shirt.
Maybe it is a whole shirt.
Maybe you just ate so much that now we can see your belly again.
You know,
like you ever see a woman with big tits were and a half shirt.
And then when you turn around and look at her,
it goes all the way down to our ass in the back and it's like,
oh,
that's not an APP.
She just has giant tits.
She can't help it.
It's not her fault.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
I took my daughter,
we went out for a walk today and we went up,
we went on a hike and,
uh,
you know,
I was pushing this stroller the whole way up with a great workout,
man.
You go up the fucking hills pushing a stroller,
you know?
Yeah.
That's an extra 25 pounds right there.
Just pushing it out,
pushing it up the Goddamn Hill.
I saw this guy hiking with his daughter and his son is,
it got a little older.
I thought it was really cool.
It's like,
man,
I'd love to do that someday.
You know?
Although his son was still wearing his pajamas,
I was just like,
come on man.
You gotta tell him,
put his clothes on.
But then I was thinking like,
damn,
I least my favorite pajamas and I would of caved to.
Oh,
right.
All right.
Son.
No,
I would
and I'd be like,
all right,
well you wear them in the house.
Yeah,
but I,
oh whoa.
Where am I?
Right then we're not going hiking.
Ah,
you well join the club son joined the club.
Um,
I,
I really don't even know what the Fuck I've been talking about.
I'm just trying to fill up time here.
That's all I do here on this podcast.
If you new to it,
I'll tell you right now,
I've never been so offended in my life that someone actually has the audacity to
make fun of the vanity of Hollywood and the Boston Celtics.
Okay.
From two of the most simple combination championship combination cities ever.
Yeah.
What does Cleveland,
Cleveland is zero.
The Indians.
One in 48.
I'll throw another one in there.
Let me,
they fuck up one that's like,
they're like zero one,
two.
You know
when it comes to championships,
I swear to God there should be a Fisher price tag hanging off the ones in
Cleveland.
I'm saying your children,
when it comes to success.
Oh,
pill.
What?
Why would she go back into that bucket of hate?
Because it's good.
It's finally,
I must use the line from bread,
Dawn.
It keeps me warm.
All that hates going to burn you up.
Keeps me warm.
Powers booth.
Was it powers but was power powers booth in Atlanta?
Yeah.
Um,
what a fucking name I powers booth.
All right,
you guys see Morgan Freeman gotten a little bit of trouble this week.
I,
you know,
nobody said how fucking cool it is than an 80 year old guy could still fuck.
You know what I mean?
I mean that,
why can't we look at the bright side of sexual harassment and plus he's at,
he's 80 I mean,
what,
what do you think he's going to do?
I mean,
you stopped listening to music a couple of years after high school.
You get married,
you have a kid,
you don't know what the fuck's going on.
This guy doesn't know what's going away.
What are you gonna do next?
Make Fun of the playlist on his flip phone.
He said his fucking eighties.
Okay.
Oh my God.
I was so afraid.
I was so afraid when that guy pushing hundred,
that clip where he was saying,
I wish I was there.
I thought he was making fun of Michael Caine going,
I wish I was there when you stuck your foot in your mouth saying are you
pregnant?
And the woman wasn't.
That's how I took it.
I have no idea,
but what would I know?
What would I know about male and female relationships?
Okay,
what the fuck would I know?
What was I looking up again?
Okay.
CLEVELAND,
the Cleveland Indians.
This is such a country thing to do after they just had success to talk about
their entire pastures,
but this is all I got.
This is you should listen to me is a sad,
pathetic man taking swings at people who are no longer in the room.
They've moved on Cleveland Indians.
I want to,
I want to coin them.
What is it?
What is your,
your combination what?
Cleveland Indians,
world series champion chips and I put it plural out of respect.
World series titles too.
So they got two world series,
one NBA zero Superbowls and we'll give them the fucking Columbus blue jackets
with zero Stanley cups.
So the combination to Cleveland is zero zero one two.
All right.
Do you understand we've one more super bowls than you have.
Why am I doing this?
This is so checked cause it's fun.
I'm not doing it to all Cleveland.
I'm just doing it to the fucking how do you only went to Superbowl?
I mean two world series and you have like 58 retired numbers.
What'd you retire the numbers from it for?
If I have enough fucking jumping on the grenade and joining that franchise.
Oh Bell.
I like the Cleveland Indians.
You don't really as I kind of just had a great weekend and I don't really have
anything to talk about.
Uh Oh by the way,
did anybody see the highlight?
I,
I dunno what I did.
I tried to favorite the thing on,
on,
uh,
my Instagram page,
which by the way,
I suck at it.
Like I'm not making these stupid videos going.
Like,
man,
it'd be the groceries tool to fucks up with cantaloupe.
Check me out at the San Jose Improv.
Um,
did you see that fucking Guy Moto GP race without that fucking guy?
I can't even describe what he,
basically,
he's thick.
They're all coming around the corner.
They're about two inches from each other.
One guy wipes out
okay.
And his bike lands perpendicular to the guy behind him.
All right.
And the guy just hits the gas and drives up over it like a fucking stuck man.
He's going a 100 something miles an hour.
He goes flying through the fucking air and then lands on gravel and somehow
saves it and doesn't go down and continues on.
Oh.
And by the way,
like his airbag pot and if you ever seen those guys when they get off,
the bikes were after they wipe out their arms looking weird,
like then like they were in these weird,
you know when somebody gets knocked out in their arms,
kind of go doing,
they kind of stick out.
They do that a little bit.
I'm guessing that's because the airbag popped in.
They can't bring their arms back down.
This guy's airbag popped,
making them less aerodynamic.
He continued to ride the f the race.
I mean,
it's just fucking bad ass bad ass.
You know what I miss?
I miss the fucking Indy 500 after interviewing Danica Patrick.
Um,
who by the way,
it was so fucking bad ass.
And um,
I think it's really cool that she's retiring,
you know,
retire while you still have some years left,
it doesn't look,
uh,
you know,
you don't want to limp out of the league.
Like fucking,
you know,
Brett Farve,
I don't really think of those last few years,
but it's just like,
dude,
you're in there,
you're a hall of fame.
You one of the greatest ever.
What are you doing?
Um,
you want to get out before then?
and then she'll say like a vineyard or something like that.
It's really a,
that's the way to do it.
That's the way to get out of show business.
You know,
I think the smothers brothers did that.
Like they didn't even announced their retirement.
They,
from what I heard,
I was working in Vegas.
They did their last show at the Orleans casino.
Didn't say it was the last show.
Just said thank you,
good night and just fucking
wet.
Retired to their vineyard.
How fucking bad.
I mean that is,
that's,
that's it.
Like with Jordan hit that last shot as a bull.
Smothers brothers didn't come back to play for the fucking wizards.
Yeah.
Um,
all right,
so Celtics lost that game seven.
And I am in the last days of my forties.
I am basically sitting here with a bottle of tampons and some Kleenex.
This,
this is,
this is the end of it,
man.
You know,
I mean,
Jesus,
I look really good for fucking 50 I'm not going to lie,
but I'm going to tell you right now,
nobody looks good at 60.
Okay?
I don't give a fuck what you do when you're 60 you're 60 and all even,
and that's not true.
Kenny Aronoff did my podcast.
He looked fucking unbelievable.
And he was a little north of 60.
All right,
that's it,
Katie era.
Kenny aronoffs.
Now the guy I'm looking at,
all right,
the day that guy falls off,
whatever fucking year that is,
I'm gonna be like God.
And that's officially you fucking oath,
right?
There you go.
Um,
anyways,
let me,
let me read a little bit of advertising here.
Fucking all over the Goddamn man.
Oh,
look who it is.
Indochino oh.
Stig.
Stig looks great in his sixties.
Yeah.
Um,
talk about how a made to measure suit fits compared to a generic off the rack
suit.
Well,
unless you the size of a fucking mannequin.
Yeah.
This good is going to be some problems.
Was that good in don't cheat out is the world's largest made to measure men's
wear company and has been featured in major publications including Gq,
Forbes,
and fast company.
Fast Company is at about whores.
Guys love the wide selection of high quality and the option to personalize all
details including your pal or your lapel.
All right,
that's fucking cool.
Lining and monogram old school shit.
You get your initials put on the sleeve.
Come on.
Here's how it works.
Visit a showroom or a shop online and@indochino.com pick your fabric,
choose your customization,
submit your measurements,
weight for your custom suit to arrive at just a few weeks.
Uh,
you got to do that.
It's fucking cool.
This week my listeners can get any premium Indochino suit for just 379
bucks@indochino.com when entering Burb,
B u r r at checkout,
that's 50% off the regular price for a made to fuckin measure premium suit plus
shipping is free.
That's indochino.com promo code bar for any premium suit for just $379 and free
shipping.
Incredible deal for a suit that will fit you better than anything off the wreck
ever could.
All right,
what did we go?
Oh my God.
Dollar Shave Club,
dude.
Dude,
you have a shower or brush your teeth to try to make you a hey ya look
presentable.
Hey,
here's some good news.
Dollar Shave Club has a lot of stuff to help you out.
The ugly bastard dollar shave.
Yeah,
ugly smelly bastard.
This is the copy.
Should be less than dollar shave club knows there's a lot of ugly smelly
bastards out there trying to get a piece of Pie.
You know,
you want to stop looking so ugly and smell a little better.
Go to dollar shave club.
Yes.
That's dollar shave club that delivers everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best.
You name it.
Shampoo,
conditioner,
body wash,
toothpaste,
Hair Gel.
Hey,
a gel,
even a wipe that alleviate Tush.
Philip Tingley clean.
You'll be a big fan.
You know?
You know what those one wipe Charlies are though?
Cherry.
Oh Cherry.
Those are the fucking,
that's the poor man's Butt Day.
I got to get some of those.
You know who doesn't want their ass?
Finland so fresh.
It's so clean.
You'll be a big fan of their amber and Labrador calming body cleanser after you
try it the first time when you're dragging yourself fucking roofie.
Good luck finding a product that grade at the store.
All Dollar Shave club's products are made with the top shelf and ingredients.
Gradients that won't break your budget.
You'll feel that they're good.
They get grey goose vodka and there's soap plus shipping is included with your
membership.
I actually like Belvedere better and here's a great way to try a bunch of dollar
shave club products for just five bucks.
You can get their daily essential style set.
Yeah,
this is for men.
Honey.
Have you seen my daily essential starters set?
It comes with body cleanser,
one wipe Chari.
They're amazing,
but wipes they're world famous shave butter and their best razor.
This six blade executive,
uh,
keep the blades coming for a few bucks more a month and add in shampoo,
toothpaste or anything else you need.
Speaking of your next month for a limited time,
only use the code burr at checkout to get $5 off your second month of the club.
That's Code
burr@dollarshaveclub.com to save $5 on your second month.
Join the club today,
stamps.com lastly,
but not leastly the US Postal Service is an important tool for any business.
Buy and print official US postage for any letter,
any package.
Eddie class of bail using your own computer and printer stamps.com makes it easy
like that girl up the street there.
They'll send you a digital scale,
automatically calculates exact postage stamps.com we'll even help you decide the
best class that mail based dot needs.
No need to lease an expensive postage meter.
And there are no long term commitments.
No Way.
A lady,
I use stamps.com anytime I send out my fucking posters,
I'm a moron if I can figure it out.
So can you
include your personal recommendation?
I just did absolutely no negative references to the post office.
Oh No,
I love the post office.
And right now you too can enjoy the stamps.com servers with this special offer
that includes a four week trial plus postage and a digital scale.
Why can't I trash your competition?
The post office,
maybe this is the post office's side piece,
you know,
this is how they're going to gracefully get out of the business.
I don't know.
Was that negative?
It wasn't negative.
It was just speculation.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburgerthatstamps.com and to burn.
All right,
podcast is going to be a little,
little short this week.
Everybody,
you know it's going to be a,
just like that guy in taxi,
you know on uh,
what the,
what is the fucking show there?
The fucking,
so we sunny in Philadelphia,
spacing on the guy's name.
He was Osen in one flew over the cuckoo's nest.
He was in kindergarten cop.
No,
he wasn't.
He was in twins.
He was in romancing the stone,
I think.
Yeah.
Keep Thinking Allen.
All the
fuck he got drunk on that talk show was hilarious.
Louie Depalma.
You know what I'm talking about anyways,
uh,
or read the four skin injections,
wine,
country advice,
a Billy Barolo breath.
Heard you talking to Danica Patrick about why you said you and Nia want to do a
wine country trip.
Thought I'd give you some ideas.
I grow grapes and make wine for a small producer in Sonoma county and I've been
in the wine industry for 10.
All right.
You have established credibility.
Why can't you just tell me where the fuck to go rather than reading me your
entire resume,
you self-involved jackass.
How soon before this guy has fucking Korean for skin cells injected into his
fucking
great teeth,
make his teeth white again after all that Murlow
um,
I am not drinking Marlo.
I guess that fucked up the whole Merlow industry.
I like Marillo.
Um,
first of all,
don't do Napa.
It's Douchey is fuck.
Honestly,
you only need to drive a couple hours into Santa wine as valley for an Austin
weekend of wine tasting.
They have all kinds of great wines there,
but if you guys do want to come all the way up to the quote real wine country,
I really do think Sonoma county is better than Knapek Napa County.
The mistake people make is going to the actual town of Sonoma,
which is boring and pretty shitty.
Uh,
the move is to stay in Hell's stowed.
You're hooking me up Helzberg,
which is in northern Sonoma county,
shitloads of excellent tasting rooms and restaurants just walking around town
plus tons of other wineries nearby to drive
to slash hire a car.
Napa is only an hour away at most.
So you could always cruise over there for a day.
If there are some specific Napa wineries you want to check out,
if okay,
if there's some specific ones you want to check out,
but seriously,
Fuck Napa blown up way over price wide,
most of them,
which aren't great and they can't even grow Pinot noir over there.
It's too hot and peanut is the best wine there is.
Once you learn to notice and appreciate the little details.
Bonus fact Les Claypool has a winery here.
He makes peanut because he knows what's up.
I fucking love Les Claypool
shaped baby.
Do you want to fucking drink wine with me?
Um,
other football leagues.
Well thank you sir.
I'm going to fucking copy and paste that and send that to my class and see what
she says.
Or other football leagues.
Hey William Shit.
Just one.
Oh,
you know what?
I missed the Liverpool Cup final.
I'll have to catch their next game next season.
Evidently I don't even know who won.
I would think uh,
Liverpool one I lost because I didn't get any fucking,
hey dude,
I hope you watched your adopted team one Liverpool Cup final.
Uh,
Geez against Madrid.
Where the fuck is it over here?
Why is my cable so slow now?
Cable my Internet.
Come on.
You fuck hoes?
Why?
Well,
I don't fucking know.
Well you don't.
Evidently my computer is allergic to soccer.
Uh,
okay.
Other football leagues.
Hey William shivers was wondering since Johnny Manzel has made the switch,
if you ever watch any CFL,
I love the CFL.
CFL is so fucking underrated.
CFL is better than college football.
That's a bunch of college.
All stars that weren't quite good enough to make it to the NFL.
But what have any college football team,
bigger field.
It's exciting.
I don't even know what the fuck's going on.
And there's only like six teams,
right?
The Edmonton Eskimos.
They like your Washington Redskins,
right?
Are they getting pressure to change that name?
The Calgary rough riders.
The BCA Eagles on,
it's a Calgary stampede,
right?
Isn't it
the Winnipeg nostrils stickers,
something like that.
Something about the cold weather out there.
I don't fucking know.
Um,
oh,
by the way,
tonight's the first night of the Stanley Cup finals,
right?
Stanley Cup final,
not the NBA finals.
Stanley Cup.
Final and congratulations to the fucking Vegas nights and the Washington
capitals.
That's going to be exciting to see the team win.
But a,
I'm really pulling for the capitals.
I'm a big,
I'm a big fan of a fucking,
what's his face say?
Oh,
Vegan.
You know,
Russian players get a bad name in the NHL.
Uh,
cause uh,
I guess a number of them could give a fuck about winning a Stanley Cup.
You know,
who is that guy that signed,
you know,
was fucking amazing.
Played for the Atlanta thrashers,
got a giant contract with New Jersey was just like,
yeah,
you know,
I just don't give a fuck.
And he left,
went back to play hockey and uh,
Russia like the Stanley Cup does,
like that's the stereotype that it doesn't mean shit to these guys.
All right.
So guys,
like,
you know,
Malkan in Ovechkin got a bear.
The,
the,
the carry a load of these other Russian cuts that I guess didn't give a shit.
So I'm rooting for that guy.
You know,
Trump probably wouldn't like it that I'm rooting for a Russian,
but I want to see him.
Uh,
I want to see him when one,
um,
we should,
we shall see.
But what's his face?
Uh,
Vince Neil Motley Crue,
one of my favorite groups of all time.
He's out in Vegas and he's become a big fucking Vegas Knights Fan.
So no matter what,
I'm going to be happy whoever wins.
Um,
anyways,
other football leagues,
uh,
I would absolutely watch the CFL are the biggest differences.
Our field is longer,
long and wider with bigger end zones in field goal posts are on the goal line.
Uh,
we also function on a three down system.
I'm probably a poor source for the rules,
but hey,
I'm just some jackass right into the podcast.
Well,
let me know when it starts.
Ps,
you should see a Saskatchewan rough riders game.
We are considered one of the best football fan bases around and do a show in
Saskatoon too.
While you're at it,
go fuck yourself and have a lovely day.
I did.
I did a show.
That's how I know you guys go.
Ooh,
I did a show in Saskatoon,
Saskatchewan.
I do want in Saskatoon and Regina,
the steady that rhymes with fun.
I never need to hear that again.
Um,
I'll definitely be back.
It's fucking God's country up there.
And you can see the northern lights like all your run.
Uh,
boyfriend found out I cheated on my ex husband.
Oh boy.
Uh,
Billy Babushka Lips.
What the fuck is Babushka I gotta look that up.
MMM.
Liverpool quest for glory ends in tears as Gareth Bale.
Wonderful breaks hard.
Oh No.
Well,
I had enough sports pain for the fucking weekend.
What happened?
Okay,
I'm clicking on the link.
Why won't you do anything?
All right.
What was I looking at?
Babushka
yeah,
it's one of my favorite words of all time.
I don't even know what it means.
Yeah.
Oh,
Billy Babushka.
If I was a wrestling manager,
that would be my name.
All right.
Should I end my relationship?
Uh,
my boyfriend of a year and a half fun on,
I cheated on my ex husband.
He's not being a huge dick about it.
Just passive aggressive whenever shit goes down,
which is not too often.
He's a little bit these,
a little on the sensitive side,
but until he found out about my past,
that's what I liked about him.
He's a math computer guy,
not an Alpha male.
Uh,
well,
you know,
you get what you pay for sweetheart.
He does not care what people think about him and he has a unique sense of humor.
His family definitely has mental issues.
His Dad refused to stay on dialysis and died when he was in high school and two
older brothers off themselves when he was a sophomore and a senior in college.
Jesus fucking Christ date and the Hemingways here.
I'm in my,
my mid thirties and have a good job and he's two years older and has a great
job,
owns a house in a good neighborhood.
No kids involved.
Our relationship is the best I've ever had.
I feel a lot of love recently though,
after he found out I sense a lapse.
He never wants to talk about it.
I could never imagine myself cheating again.
I got married to my ex too young,
but now that my baby making years are coming to an end,
I don't know what to do.
Should I stick around to see if we get back to where we were or move on?
Go drink yourself.
Um,
yeah.
Yeah.
I don't,
fuck I,
you know,
I don't know.
Um,
just be like,
look,
I I
ever going to be able to get,
just ask them,
are you going to be able to get past this?
You know,
here's the thing.
you did do it so
it gives you shit.
I kind of got to roll with it.
I guess I have gives a fuck.
Yeah.
I just rolled with it for a little bit and just see a full fucking sensitive,
sensitive.
Are there?
Um,
I don't know.
People always say that,
you know,
if you fucking cheat,
you're going to cheat again.
I,
and I don't know,
but it all depends on where you are in your life.
Who the fuck you with?
I don't know about that one.
Is there been a study on that?
I have no idea.
I honestly don't know what to tell you,
man.
Um,
maybe you could turn it into some sort of math joke.
Uh,
dating older women.
Dear Billy blue balls.
My name is prince.
I am 23 and about to be 24 m and about a month I am in a relationship with a 44
year old woman.
Yeah.
This is easy to get the fuck out of it.
You're not in a relationship.
You're bang in a 44 year old woman.
Uh,
now I know what you are thinking.
Mommy issues much.
No.
And I don't end fucking sentences with the word much not as I just said.
Hey,
that's too much
that there's some fucking,
I hate that.
Something something much.
You know what else you want?
I hate,
uh,
so and so,
and then at something in quotes me something in quotes in the year.
Always the coolest fucking person.
Ah,
Bill,
you're old.
Get over it.
People talk differently now.
All right.
You remember when you were young and everybody would yell?
Not,
you didn't think that was annoying to older people.
All right,
you got me now I know what you were thinking.
Okay,
now I know what you're thinking.
Mommy issues much yet.
That is part of the reason I am with her,
if I'm being honest.
Well,
there you go.
Gotta love honesty.
We have been dating for about five months now and things are good,
but there are things that irritate the hell out of me.
What?
Her fucking silver pubic hair.
Uh,
like she thinks some of my views on life and other things are odd.
I honestly think it's because she grew up in a totally different times.
Yeah.
It's called a generation gap.
If he gets your face out of her gap and look at the fucking calendar,
sorry.
MMM.
We had been dating for about five months now and things are good.
No,
they're not.
But there are things that irritate.
Okay,
I read this.
They're not good,
sir.
You need to get the fuck out of this.
This is not gonna end.
Well,
at some point you're going to want to have a kid.
All right?
And a vagina is going to be in a fucking museum.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
where the fuck was something that definitely different time than me,
but some of it is that she isn't into science.
Oh,
she better be if going to try to keep herself
young.
Like we got into an argument about high fructose corn syrup because she said
it's only sugar until I proved to her that it's not just sugar and she thinks
that's not really science.
Yeah.
I thought you were into science.
You're just reading facts that scientists figured out that's not science.
Right.
I mean,
I could,
the fact that I could look that up and just go,
here it is.
That's not scientist.
If I can figure it out,
it's not science,
sir.
Um,
and she thinks my fear of chemicals in our food is odd as well.
It's hard being with someone that doesn't get me another thing in a nother thing
in a black male.
Oh,
I'm a black male and she's a white female,
so she doesn't really understand how it is to be a black man in this day and
age.
Jesus fucking Christ,
sir.
How many red flags that you need?
You know,
and,
and she's,
uh,
she got fired from the Police Department for dropping the n word.
Other than that,
I think I really like her.
Sarah,
what the fuck are you doing?
I'm going to keep going here and to jump taught,
uh,
ended jump topic.
Uh,
sex with her is good,
but it's like we only have sex once and it sucks.
She says it's because I leave her too,
so,
okay.
I'm not,
I leave her to soar as you know.
Is there anything worse than a big fucking Dick?
Nincompoop I can't fucking,
I know at 1:00 AM 1:00 AM I supposed to do with you sir?
You and your porno cockney to fucking date somebody,
uh,
you know,
from,
she's almost twice your age
and she listens to country,
but this is such a fucked up email.
I don't believe it.
I'm calling bullshit on that one.
Yeah,
you kind of did a slow roll on me.
You had me,
you had me,
you had me.
And then you said I'm black and I got a big deck and she,
so I don't believe it.
I don't believe it.
Maybe it's true.
He goes,
I want to have excitement and shit in our relationship.
And she just doesn't bring that to the table.
I like her a lot and we watched documentaries together.
I'm sure that she fall asleep halfway through it like I do.
Um,
anyways.
All right.
Okay.
And she has a venereal disease,
but you know,
other than that,
you know,
we laugh a lot.
Ah,
fuck.
All right.
Do we have anything else here?
Is there anything else that that needs to be discussed other than why is my
computer that I got kicked off line?
You know,
and now it'd be funny if I never go to the Internet again in the last thing I
did was I looked up Babushka
um,
all right.
People,
it's Memorial Day.
Who's kidding?
Who you're not fucking working today either.
All right.
I have to go to a picnic.
That kid picnic and I can't wait.
You know what?
I actually got a great book here.
It says 88 great daddy daughter dates.
And I think I'm going to do most of these,
you know,
I got all these books.
You know,
uh,
dad's prayers for his daughter's daughter.
That's fucking weird.
Strong fathers,
strong daughters,
10 secrets every father should know.
All right,
let's read a little bit of this sandwich to the Segree.
Protect her.
Defend her.
Okay.
She needs,
oh my God.
How awful.
This is like,
all right.
How dumb would you have to be to read this fucking book?
Okay.
One,
you are the most important man in her life.
Chapter two,
she needs a hero.
Chapter three,
you are her first love chapter four,
teacher humility.
Oh,
she shouldn't stand there like a Lebron James after you just blocked a shot.
Uh,
protect her,
defend her and use a shotgun if necessary.
Pragmatism and grit.
Your two greatest,
I'll read that chapter because I don't know what either one of those means.
I know one of them was a John Wayne movie.
Be the man you want her to marry.
Gross.
Uh,
teacher.
Who God is gross teacher to fight.
That's right.
There you go.
Keep her connected
afterward.
Acknowledgments,
bibliography,
notes,
index.
I don't know what those last three chapters were about.
Let's see.
Let's read the chapter.
We'll start with index here.
Let's see what the Hell I'm supposed to tell my daughter a abortion.
12 abstinence comma went 13 dash one 14 I,
this doesn't make any sense.
Add health study,
ADHD
advertising,
African Americans.
This book is all over the place.
African Americans and it says depression and s t
ds
aids.
But why did you have to drag black people into this?
Alcohol use is a weird chapter.
I don't think I liked this book.
I know that.
I don't know who wrote.
Um,
anyways,
oh,
fucking Billy burger face going to go fucking turn on the grill.
Make a few here.
Um,
this is one of my last podcasts in my forties.
This is so stupid.
I'm turning 50.
I'm not going to feel any fucking differently.
Um,
I'm definitely gonna try to eat better and I've been doing that for the last
three months and I was facetiming with somebody and they would like to have you
lost weight.
And I was like,
Nah,
not really.
Yeah.
Woo.
I was excited.
Um,
so anyways,
um,
I think that's it,
right?
Anything.
I'm doing a drum,
do my double bass drum.
It's coming along.
It's coming along,
you know,
working on that song.
I,
the beholder.
I the bowl holder for little Metallica.
Oh.
And I played streets of San Francisco.
It's all serendipity.
All right.
This is,
this is it.
I'm done.
I'm not going to just fucking meander for another fucking six minutes just to
say I did it once again.
I apologize everybody.
Cleveland and in Philly for being a contact,
right?
You want a Superbowl?
Congratulations.
You go in the NBA finals.
I hope you fucking cheese steaks.
And whenever the fuck it is,
you guys eat there in Cleveland.
I hope they taste extra better today.
Extra special.
All right,
I'm off to watch some baseball.
Oh.